all right welcome back to pftpm joining
us now live from tampa you got there
yesterday it's a different week shireen
and i aren't there peter is it's peter
king of nbc sports peter how different
is the experience there than it's been
in past years
it's just so quiet i mean when i got
here yesterday mike um it was really a
ghost town
you drive into the hotel where i'm
staying here and all the big downtown
hotels
and i had to go looking i i got here at
noon and i had to go looking for a uh
for a valet to take the keys to the car
i mean you know i mean i got to do
something with the car
and uh that's
it's just a very different week and
today i was over at the media center
and uh there's 160 places in four
separate media rooms over there i'm
there at 1 30 in the afternoon on a
friday there are seven people total
working
uh in the media center seven seven
and so it's just gonna be a different
year i mean there's gonna be 78
reporters in the press box normally
there's 600
so it's just it's a different world and
you just have to take it that way
peter we've both been to a ton of super
bowls and roger goodell said yesterday
that he expected tampa to get special
consideration for the next open super
bowl which is three years away but in
all your experiences of covering all
these super bowls where does tampa rank
as a super bowl site for you
i mean i think it's a good site i don't
think it's you know it's not new orleans
it's not i mean i always thought san
diego was fabulous
and you know tampa bay i think is going
to get hurt in the future
by uh
you know la rejoining the mix
i mean at some point vegas is going to
get a super bowl at least one and maybe
more than that
so but but i do think that this market
absolutely deserves to i'm not even
saying jump the line cut the line but
i've got some good friends down here who
were in business and they were telling
me today i had coffee with one of them
this morning
and uh he was telling me that basically
it's 75 80 percent
of the business that they expect from a
normal super bowl
that's how much it's off so
i think the nfl uh especially
because you know the glazer family they
want they always do these things for
owners okay and i think the glazer
family is is probably feeling the heat
amiable heat from a lot of people in
tampa who are just making no money off
this super bowl
you mentioned 78 reporters will be in
the press box at the game
all year long reporters haven't been
allowed in the locker room i i assume
that's still the case and i think of
some of the great stories you've
harvested over the years in the locker
room after the game what's your plan for
getting to the bottom of the key play
the key moment the key drive this year
mike i'm
i i hate to say it but i'm the only
person in tampa here on friday night
who's really depressed
because because last year i sat with
andy reid in his office and he
drew up on a piece of paper to jet chip
wasp
and
it's funny i got to kansas city
on my training camp trip my very
abbreviated one this year and went and
got a cheeseburger at andy reed's
favorite place town topic and the guy in
front of me in line had a t-shirt that
said two jet chip wasp and so i'm
thinking to myself hey i had something
to do with that t-shirt
i don't know mike i i'm not optimistic
but we'll just have to see what happens
it's going to be a very tough
night to try to really get some insight
that people really need and i uh
i'm rooting for myself but i'm a little
dubious
peter you got to ask roger goodell a
question yesterday at his press
conference as you normally do what was
your biggest takeaway from that press
conference yesterday
that
roger goodell cannot do anything about
the owners not hiring
a significant number of minority coaches
as i said
to goodell at the press conference look
the rooney rule was invented in 2003 and
in 2003 there were three black coaches
in the nfl
and in
2021 there will be three black coaches
in the nfl now obviously uh robert sala
and ron rivera are minority coaches who
are not black and that's obviously a
good thing to have more minority
representation but
you know the nfl owners talk a very good
game and simply don't deliver
and to think that i'm not one of those
who say the only candidate is eric b
enemy or the only candidate is todd
bowles
but they're excellent candidates and
there's other excellent candidates like
byron leftwich and
and and jim caldwell and leslie frazier
and
you know the
the owners have to step up to the plate
there's only so many times that roger
goodell could slap him all in the head
and say what is wrong with you and why
aren't you doing a better job in
minority hiring particularly when it
comes to black coaches
peter the slap's got to come from the
outside if it's ever going to get the
attention of the nfl i was talking to
coach dungey earlier today and i told
him if i was practicing law and i was
representing
a plaintiff who claimed that he did not
get a head coaching job based upon
racial bias i said i i would say i don't
care about the process show me the
result look at the result time after
time it's like flipping a coin a
thousand times in a row and it keeps
coming up heads at a certain point the
result proves the bias and he told me
that was cyrus mary's argument back when
they adopted the rooney rule that's what
he used to squeeze the nfl into passing
the rooney rule that rule was passed
under the threat of litigation and i'm
convinced peter until there is a viable
threat of litigation they're not going
to take this seriously
well mike i'll tell you that you know
steve weich of nfl network uh jim
trotter as well have been banging the
drum that
uh the
the group the core of coaches
um
you know the black assistant coaches are
as depressed as they ever have been and
i can tell you that last weekend when
that discussion turned to one of the new
coordinators
uh for an nfl team
that
you know in talking to that coordinator
um
i can just tell you that he just about
has given up
and and i don't want to name names
because we're off the record but in
essence i do think that
there are an awful lot of good coaches
in the nfl right now who have given up
on a dream of ever being head coaches in
the nfl
peter tomorrow we have the awards that
are going to be announced and also the
hall of fame which you and i both
participated in that uh two and a half
weeks ago and surprisingly they've kept
this pretty much under wrapped so far
but what are your expectations uh for
the hall of fame and the announcement
tomorrow night
you know sheree and i think there's
going to be a surprise or two i just i
don't know what they are i and you know
quite honestly i don't want to know i
simply don't want to know because
you know the the hall of fame wants this
to be a secret
um i have not talked to people
to other voters on the committee
i don't want to know who they voted for
we'll see when it when it comes out i'm
probably a little naive probably it will
get leaked but i will say this
i think that obviously peyton manning is
going to get in and then after that i
would say in order
it goes charles woodson and then calvin
johnson and then it is anybody's guess
in my opinion just my sense
i think that john lynch
um has gotten an awful lot of support
both last year and this year i think
he's a very good candidate and the one
candidate that i think kind of came out
of nowhere to me that i think is very
interesting is clay matthew senior
who had such a great career and it's
unbelievable this is his last year
eligible as a modern era finalist and
it's the first year he's ever had his
case discussed in the room and i think
his case is extremely strong
and personally
for those who don't understand this if
you don't get in as a modern era
finalist what happens is
you get into the senior pool and there
are 100 120 130 really good candidates
in the senior pool and i don't need to
be morbid but clay matthews could die
before his case is ever brought up again
drew pearson is the senior candidate
this year peter shireen presented him
and look this is the separate category
where it's one guy it's up or down it
feels like the momentum is always in
favor of the guy getting in because
otherwise it's a wasted spot any reason
to think he's not going to get in
no i would expect drew pearson um
you know in the senior committee i would
expect bill nunn the steelers scout
uh in the contributors committee and i
would expect tom flores
in the coaches committee i think they
all have very good chances because as
you say mike
basically 11
voters would have to vote against them
they need they only need 80 percent to
get in and i don't mean only but you
know most of the time when you get to
that level you are going to get at least
38 voters voting for you
and peter we have the awards tomorrow
night too we think aaron rodgers is
probably gonna win it alex smith seems
like a lock for comeback player any
awards that you think we could see a
little curveball coming up
you know shireen it it's i think there's
a distinct lack of drama this year
and and look nobody i i hate to say it
nobody really cares is offensive player
of the year it really doesn't matter and
it's
really it's like it doesn't matter
because it's a weird vote it's a weird
vote it just is derek henry is i would
think is going to win that he's the
eighth person ever to rush for 2 000
yards in a season i'm like everybody
else i don't want to double down on my
mvp which was aaron rodgers
and i don't want to double down and have
my offensive player be aaron rodgers
give it to somebody else and that's a
weird thing i wish we would do something
about that quite honestly in those votes
but you know chase young is almost
certain i would think to be the
defensive rookie the offensive rookie
justin herbert followed by justin
jefferson and then obviously alex smith
come back player of the year now i do
think the coach of the year has some
drama i voted for kevin stefanski but i
think it could be any one of a number of
coaches but beyond that i i just i don't
see the drama this year sheree
yeah i think it's going to be stefanski
i think he nailed it down when he got
into the playoffs the final week and the
dolphins with brian flores didn't i
think that's the difference maker peter
before we let you go what's the
itinerary what's the schedule what are
you going to do over the next couple of
days in this crazy different experience
in tampa
i'm going out to dinner with a few
buddies tonight uh but tomorrow socially
distant but tomorrow i'm going to sit
right here in my little hole and i'm
going to try to get about 3 500 words
done for my column on monday there's
really mike it's so strange there's like
nothing on the agenda
you know you easily could fly in here on
sunday morning and it would be fine
but it's just a different year i had a
good conversation today with alan sills
about the future and about what they've
learned that i'm going to write about
for my column on monday and i think his
what's so interesting right now as we
look at it
is that alan roger goodell said this
yesterday and alan sills said it today
basically peter i'm not getting cocky we
got another game and it's the biggest
game of the year so you know let's let's
pat ourselves on the back on monday and
not today
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports